قوات الاحتياطي المركزي السودانيه
هي قوه شرطيه تم انشاؤها عام 1990 وهي من
الادارات المهمه بقوات الشرطه وتقع
قيادتها بالكلاكله جنوب الخرطوم وتنتشر في
العاصمه والولايات تم تدريب عناصرها
للقيام بعمليات المسلحه وشاركت قبل اعوام
في عمليات قتاليه مع الجيش في ولايه
دارفور وجنوب كوردفان والنيل الازرق وشرق
السودان سلاحها اقرب لسلاح الجيش وبها فرق
عمليات خاصه تتدرب على يد القوات الخاصه
بالقوات المسلحه بدات الانتشار يوم السبت
بجنوب الخرطوم على ان يتوالى نزولها
لمناطق اخرى من العاصمه هذه القوات خاضعه
لعقوبات امريكيه منذ مارس من عام 2022
بتهمه استخدام القوه المفرطه ضد محتجين في
الخرطوم
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات